V
AND LET'S GET BACK TO
"GUTFELD!."
>> Greg: LOOK AT THAT, YOU ARE
HERE.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
AND BRUCE JENNER.
I'M KIDDING, KAITLYN ISN'T USING
IT SO I FIGURED WHY NOT?
IT IS A BOX IT AT A BALL GAME
CURATIVE EMPTY MIGHT AS WELL
MOVE INTO THE CHEAT SHEET.
[LAUGHTER]
ANYWAY, IN ALL SERIOUSNESS YOU
HAVE TO HAND IT TO CAITLIN
BECAUSE IT TOOK BALLS THE SIZE
OF WEATHER BALLOONS TO CRITICIZE
MEDIA DARLING LEO THOMAS.
SINGH FILE GNOMIC BIOLOGICAL
BOYS SHOULD NOT COMPETE AGAINST
BIOLOGICAL GIRLS AND SHE MAY NOT
BE ONTO WHEATIES COVER ANYMORE
BUT THE SPOKESPERSON FOR
PLANNERS BECAUSE SHE'S GOT MAJOR
NUTS ON HER.
BY THE WAY WHEATIES IS THE WORST
TASTING CEREAL EVER AND COUNT
CHOCOLATE TASTE LIKE A STATE
GNOMIC STEAK.
NO FAT PERSON WOULD DARE EAT IT.
NOW SHE HAS NO BEEF WITH THOMAS
BUT FELT THE NCAA WAS NOT TOUGH
ENOUGH IN ALLOWING THOMAS TO
COMPETE IN WOMEN'S RACES.
AND SHE'S RIGHT.
THOMAS NEEDS A BUNCH OF
BIOLOGICAL GIRLS AND 500-METER
WHATEVER.
HONESTLY I DON'T FOLLOW IT.
SWIMMING IS FOR PEOPLE TOO LAZY
TO BATHE AFTER EXERCISING.
SORRY, TRACE.
IN THIS CONTROVERSY OF LETTING
BIOLOGICAL MALES BEEF BIOLOGICAL
FEMALES, THERE HAS TO BE A
SUSTAINED POSITION TO TAKE.
FIRST OF ALL TO SWITCH GENDERS
TO BE GIRLS BEFORE YOU SUCK THAT
BECAUSE CHEATING WITH STEROIDS
WOULD BE EASIER BUT REMEMBER AS
A DUDE, RANKED AT 4621 SPOT
AHEAD OF HER RUSTY ANCHOR.
AND NOW AS A CHECK, SHE IS
NUMBER ONE.
SHE SHOULD BE THE SPOKESPERSON
FOR CHLORINE, STRONG ENOUGH FOR
A MAN BUT MADE FOR A WOMAN.
BUT I WONDER IF THE CONTROVERSY
MATTERS TO HER OR DOES SHE TRY
TO IGNORE IT?
>> I TRIED TO IGNORE IT AS MUCH
AS I CAN.
I TRIED TO FOCUS ON MY SWIMMING,
WHAT I NEED TO DO TO GET READY
FOR MY RACES AND JUST TRY TO
BLOCK OUT EVERYTHING ELSE.
>> Greg: OKAY THAT IS WEIRDLY
SELFISH.
LIKE ME PUTTING ON A DRESS AND
DOING "THE VIEW" AND ACTING LIKE
IT IS NO BIG DEAL.
THE SAD THING IS I WOULD STILL
BE HONORED.
BUT I WOULD ALSO KICK THEIR, IT
IS THE VIEW AND THEY NEED
THE SUPPORT TO COUNT TO TEN BUT
IT IS NOT ABOUT SWITCHING
GENDERS AT ALL.
THAT IS A DISTRACTION.
RUNNING SWIM MEETS IS NOT THE
ONLY REASON TO CHANGE YOUR.
I WILL NOT GO NEAR A KIDDIE POOL
BUT IT IS ABOUT WHAT YOU DO
AFTER SWITCHING GENDERS.
IT IS COMMON SENSE.
YOU MIGHT CALL IT COMMON
COURTESY.
PERHAPS WHAT THOMAS IS DOING IS
A BYPRODUCT OF MASSIVE
SELFISHNESS LIKE EATING AN
ENTIRE PIZZA YOU WERE SUPPOSED
TO SAY FOR YOUR SPOUSE WHEN SHE
GOT HOME FROM WORK.
THAT IS THE STRIKING PART.
A DUDE BECOMES A MAN AND KICKS
THE OUT OF GIRLS IN THE SPORT.
IT IS PIGGISH.
NOT MANY WOMEN ARE BECOMING MEN
AND DOING THE SAME THING OR IF
THEY DO, THEY LOSE MORE THAN
HILLARY CLINTON.
SO THE MORE THOMAS WINS AS A
CHECK THE MORE OF A CHAUVINIST
SHE APPEARS TO BE.
I MEAN YOU SHOULD SEE THAT EVEN
IF YOUR BANGS ARE IN YOUR EYES.
NO ONE IS SAYING IT IS WRONG TO
PURSUE THE SPORT YOU LOVE BUT
WHEN YOU HAVE A CLEAR ADVANTAGE
AND FOR SOME REASON YOU DON'T
CARE, IT IS DISRESPECTFUL AND
NARCISSISTIC BUT BY STICKING UP
FOR WOMEN, JENNER SHOWS THE
RESPECT SHE HAS FOR THE FAIRER
SEX WHICH LIA THOMAS HAPPILY
DESTROYS THE COMPETITION.
AND JENNER IS DOING IN THE FACE
OF THE MEDIA WHILE DESPERATELY
CLING TO THE UNTENABLE WOKE
POSITION.
NBC OP ED ACTUALLY COMPARED
THOMAS TO JACKIE ROBINSON, WHICH
IS WEIRD.
THEY DON'T LOOK AT ALL ALIKE.
EXCEPT MAYBE IN SIZE AND MUSCLE
MASS.
RICA G NOT SURE IF I GOT THAT
RIGHT A VIRGINIA TECH SWIMMER
TOOK ISSUE WITH NCAA RULES
ALLOWING GENDER TO COMPETE
AGAINST FEMALES AFTER CUT OFF
THE CONSOLATION IN THE 500
FREESTYLE, SHE BLAMED THOMAS'
DOMINANCE IN THE RACE.
IN A LETTER SHE CLAIMED THE
RULES ARE HARMFUL FOR BIOLOGICAL
FEMALES IN EVERY BAD
TRANSGENDERED ATHLETES COMPETED
IN ONE SPOT TAKEN AWAY FROM
BIOLOGICAL FEMALES, HERSELF
INCLUDED.
YOU KNOW, IT IS ALMOST
BIOLOGICAL WOMEN SHOULD HAVE
THEIR OWN LEAGUE SO THEY ARE
CRUSHED BY BIOLOGICAL MEN.
THAT IS CRAZY.
RON DeSANTIS, ISN'T HE THE
COMMISSIONER OF SWIMMING OR
SOMETHING?
IS ALSO PRETTY TICKED OFF.
>> NOW THE NCAA IS BASICALLY
TAKING EFFORTS TO DESTROY
WOMEN'S ATHLETICS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO UNDERMINE THE
END TO GNOMIC INTEGRITY OF THE
COMPETITION AND FINDING SOMEONE
ELSE, THE WOMAN'S CHAMPION AND
WE THINK THAT IS WRONG.
>> Greg: SO HE ISSUED A
PROCLAMATION WAS SECOND PLACE
FINISHER THE TRUE CHAMPION THE
IN SHORT, THE CRUSH THAT FEMALE
COMPETITION.
I'M NOT DEVASTATED BUT I'M NOT A
WOMAN WHO SWIM ALL HER LIFE
COMPETITIVELY.
I'M A BIOLOGICAL MALE THAT
BRINGS COMPETITIVE AND I GOT THE
TROPHIES AND LIVER TO PROVE IT.
SWIMMING IS SOMETHING I DO WHEN
I NEED TO PEE AT THE BEACH.
IT IS TRUE.
I'M WARMING THE WATER FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE.
I'M LOOKING AT THIS AND I CANNOT
DENY WHAT I SEEK.
THE NCAA SEEMS IN PROTECTING
WEALTH AND PROTECTING ATHLETES
BUT TO MAKE THIS IDEOLOGY WORK
YOU HAVE TO ERASE THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN TRANS AND
BIOLOGICAL WOMEN.
THAT MEANS NOT ONLY ON WOMEN
ERASED FROM THE RECORD BOOKS OF
THEIR OWN SPORT BUT BEATING THE
RACE.
MATT, NO PUN INTENDED SINCE MEN
CAN HAVE.
TOO.
WAIT UNTIL THE NEXT LIA THOMAS
COMES ALONG WITH A CONTACT SPORT
LIKE MAY BE WOMEN'S LACROSSE AND
LEAVES A TRAIL OF INJURED WOMEN
ON THE FIELD.
MAYBE THE LAWYERS WILL PAY UNCLE
OR SHOULD I SAY AUNT.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT ONE
GALLAGHER FOR SMASHING MELONS
AND SMASHING GOOD LOOKS.
TRACE GALLAGHER.
AND KNOWS THE DOJ LIKE I KNOW
THE DOJ IS VODKA AND ORANGE
JUICE.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL AIDE AND WINE
ENTHUSIAST MAGAZINE, FOX NEWS
ANCHOR.
I LIKE WINDOWS IN THE
DRUG DEALERS CARS AND ALWAYS
BLACKED OUT.
KAT TIMPF.
ALL RIGHT, I HAVE TO GO TO
TRACE.
THE FIRST TIME YOU ARE ON THE
NEW SHOW.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
YOU CLAIMED IN THE GREEN ROOM,
OUR SPACIOUS GREEN ROOM WHERE WE
HAVE THE HOT TUB THAT YOU
DISCOVERED ME.
EXPLAIN.
>> I TELL EVERYBODY THAT LIVES
YOUR SHOW, LOOK, I DISCOVERED
THE GUY.
COME ON, LISTEN, ME AND JULIE
AND I'M GLAD THE SHOW TONIGHT.
>> NO COINCIDENCE.
>> STUDIO B WEEKEND AND ROGER
CALLED AND SAID CAN I HAVE THIS
GUY GREG GUTFELD AND YOU HAVE TO
COME DOWN HERE AND PUT THEM ON
THE SHOW.
IT'S GOING TO BE GREAT.
HE IS ANALYTICAL AND FINALLY.
IT TURNS OUT IT WAS REALLY
POLITICAL AND KIND OF FUNNY.
AND CAME ON ANALYTICALLY,
TORCHED HILLARY CLINTON.
AND SHOULDN'T WE HAVE EVIDENCE
BEFORE YOU SAY SHE WAS GIVING
ORDERS TO JOHN GODEY?
[LAUGHTER]
THAT IS THE CONNECTION THERE.
SO THE NEXT TIME HE CAME ON,
MAYBE YOU SHOULD BALANCE THIS
GUY OUT A LITTLE BIT.
GET SOMEBODY ELSE SO YES.
HIGH, JULIE BANDERAS WITH
GREG GUTFELD AND NOW GREG HAS 19
SHOWS AND HIS BUDDY HAS TO BEG
TO GET ON THIS ONE.
>> Greg: WE HAVE GONE FULL
CIRCLE.
YOU DISCOVERED ME, AND I'M
ENDING YOUR CAREER.
[LAUGHTER]
TRACE, QUICKLY I WANT TO ASK YOU
YOU WERE A PRO ATHLETE AND YOU
WERE A PROFESSIONAL WATER SKIER.
>> I WAS.
>> Greg: I BET YOU LOOKED
GREAT.
>> I HAD A PICTURE.
>> Greg: I HAVE SOME, BELIEVE
ME ON THE CEILING OF MY
APARTMENT, WHICH YOU WILL SEE
LATER.
BIOLOGICAL DIFFERENCE, DOES IT
MATTER?
DO BIOLOGICAL DIFFERENCES MATTER
AND WATER-SKIING?
>> THERE WERE MEN ON THE TEAM
WERE WEARING FEMALE OUTFITS BY
DESIGN BUT THERE WERE SOME FUNNY
SKITS.
NO, BUT THE GIRLS WOULD BE ON
THE TOP AND THEN ON THE BOTTOM.
THE WHOLE CONCEPT YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND, IT IS REALLY NOT
LIATHOMAS' FAULT BECAUSE, YOU K,
SHE GOT THE TESTOSTERONE RIGHT,
THE TWO YEARS, SO IT'S ALL NCAA.
NCAA SCREW THIS UP HERE THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS A LITTLE BIT JUST
LIKE COVID A LITTLE BIT OF
SCIENCE AND POLITICS.
BUT THIS NCAA NEEDS TO
ACCOMMODATE AND COME UP WITH AN
OPEN CATEGORY.
THEY NEED TO MAKE THE RULES FIT
SO THAT THESE GIRLS AND I'M A
FATHER OF TWO DOCTORS, THESE
GIRLS DON'T WASTE THEIR WHOLE
LIVES AND HAVE SOMEONE 6'1",
RIGHT, HE'S GOT A LOT OF ARM
REACH.
SHE'S GOT A LONG ARM REACH.
SHOULDERS.
DYNAMICALLY, IT IS THE WHOLE
THING IN TWO YEARS YOU WILL SEE
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WILL
HAVE A MEN'S 15 BEST TENNIS
PLAYER WILL WAIT TWO YEARS CAN
IDENTIFY AS A FEMALE, PLAY ON
THE WOMEN'S TEAM AND HIS SERVE
OR HER SERVE WILL BE 150 MILES
AN HOUR WITH A WOMAN SERVING 12.
THESE ARE ASTRONOMICAL
DIFFERENCES THAT HAVE TO BE
WORKED OUT.
>> Greg: TO YOU BY THAT?
JULIE, DO YOU THINK ANYONE WILL
SWITCH TO WINS BOARDS?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SHE
SWITCHED TO WIN SPORTS AND LET
ME JUST SAY BECAUSE I'M A
JOURNALIST AND I HAVE SOME FACTS
HERE.
BEFORE SWITCHING, SPEAKING OF
SWITCHING FOR THE WOMEN'S TEAM
AND I DON'T MEAN THE WOMEN'S
TEAM BIOLOGICALLY.
>> Greg: GOT IT.
>> SHE WAS RANKED 462ND WHEN
COMPETING WITH OTHER MEN.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
>> BY THE WAY THIS PAST
SATURDAY --
DO AND SAY HELLO TO MY MOM.
YOU WEREN'T LISTENING.
>> NO BUT I WAS STARING.
SHE PLACED LAST IN 100 FREESTYLE
OVER THE WEEKEND HER COLLEGIATE
CAREER IS OVER.
I WOULD SAY SHE WILL REVOLVING
CURLING.
I TOO IDENTIFY AS MALE BUT YOU
CAN CALL ME SHE AND THAT IS
FINE.
SO WE HAVE THAT IN COMMON.
>> Greg: I FEEL WARM AROUND
YOU.
BUT LISTEN, WILLIAM THOMAS WAS
ONE OF THE BEST ON THE MEN'S
TEAM.
HE, THOMAS WAS AMONG THE BEST
SWIMMERS, 462 INFORMATION BUT
WELL AS A MAN.
IT WAS ONE OF THE TOP MAN THAT
CAME OVER AND CLEARLY HE IS
DOMINATING.
>> Greg: I HAD NO IDEA IF THEY
KNEW SO MUCH ABOUT THIS, DID YOU
ONLY KNOW ABOUT THIS TOPIC?
>> I THINK THE NCAA ONLY BIT OUT
BY CORRUPTION IN THE OLYMPIC
COMMITTEE.
BUT AS A GUY WHO DESPERATELY
TRIED TO GET INTO D1 COLLEGE
SPORTS AND RECRUIT FOR THE
FOOTBALL TEAM, I ENDED UP BEING
A CHEERLEADER.
BUT I WAS THE GUY THAT GOT DRUNK
COLLEGE BASKETBALL GAMES AND
THEN A LOT OF CHEERING.
>> YOU WERE IDENTIFIED AS A
CHEERLEADER.
>> THE ONLY THING THAT I
ACTUALLY LIKE BAFFLED BY IS WHAT
IS TITLE IX FOR?
LIKE I DON'T UNDERSTAND YOU
PUTTING IN SO MUCH MONEY ON
TITLE IX AND I THINK A LOT OF
AREA TO GIVE WOMEN'S SPORTS
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AS MEN'S
SPORTS.
SO DO WE NOW CROSS FUND?
DO THEY GIVE SOME FOR MEN AND
SOME FOR WOMEN?
THEY OBLITERATED TITLE IX IN A
MATTER OF WEEKS.
>> IT IS NEW GROUND BREAKING.
DO YOU HAVE SOLUTIONS FOR THIS
CONUNDRUM?
>> GREAT JOB.
>> AND SAID THAT WORD OUT LOUD.
I THINK I'M THE REAL HERO HERE.
>> SO HONESTLY, I AM TERRIFIED
TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
AND THEN I THINK WHEN I FIND
MYSELF WISHING THAT I COULD
INSTEAD TALK ABOUT A LITERAL
MOTORIST FOR THE CASSETTE FEELS
LESS TOUCHY TO ME THAN A COLLEGE
WOMEN SWIMMING COMPETITION THAT
IS THE WAY WE APPROACH THIS
COURSE THAT THERE IS A PROBLEM
THERE.
OBVIOUSLY TRANCE PHOBIA, I DO
NOT DOUBT THAT LIA THOMAS HAS
FACED TRANS-PHOBIA AND THAT IS
WRONG.
THE QUALIFICATIONS THE USA
SWIMMING RULES, THERE WERE NEW
ONES PUT INTO PLACE, NOT FOR
NCAA BUT BLATANTLY WOULD NOT
QUALIFY UNDER THOSE RULES.
SO, THERE ARE LEGITIMATE REASONS
TO THE QUESTIONS FOR THIS BUT
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH TRANCE
PHOBIA.
I THINK IT IS BAD TO JUST
BLANKET LABEL ANYONE WHO SAYS
ANYTHING SHORT OF YOU GO GIRL AS
TRANSPHOBIC.
NOT JUST FOR THE BIOLOGICALLY
FEMALE ATHLETE BUT ALSO PEOPLE
WHO WANT TRANS ACCEPTANCE
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS WHO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS AND THINK
THIS WAS NOT FAIR AND WHO ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO SAY THAT.
THAT IS NOT ACCEPTANCE.
IF ANYTHING, THAT CAN PREVENT
ACCEPTANCE BECAUSE IT BREEDS A
LOT OF FAKE.
>> Greg: I GO BACK TO MY
ORIGINAL POINT, WHY CAN'T WE
SEPARATE THE ISSUE OF CANON
SHOULD APPEAR JUST BECAUSE YOU
CAN DO SOMETHING DOESN'T MEAN
YOU SHOULD.
>> BUT I ALWAYS DO.
>> Greg: THAT I